[Musique]
la chasse au gaspillage alimentaire se
poursuit pour le jury du concours nos
gaspille mise en place par le
département
c'est au collège auguste de la caussade
à salazie qu'ils se sont rendus afin de
juger le menu imposé puis d'évaluer la
pesée des déchets s'agira pour nous
d'évaluer véritablement sa part à la
poubelle
à l'issue des prises de repas dans les
restaurants scolaires en prenant en
compte tous les éléments étudiés depuis
le début d'année bien on arrive à
élaborer un menu qui au final va
engendrer le moins de déchets sur les 77
collège de lille 15 participent au
concours pour cet établissement de
salazie il est important d'apprendre
collégiens à bien manger et à réduire
leurs déchets était important à un
niveau de notre collège qu'on puisse
participer pour que les élèves puissent
prendre conscience des enjeux du
gaspillage alimentaire et par rapport à
ce qui se passe dans la région et d'un
lied et dans le monde
pierre rodriguez chef de cuisine de
l'établissement a tout misé sur les
produits bio pour son menu idéal est
encore long mais que des produits payés
par exemple pour mes de la course qui a
une audience et frais voilà on essaye de
privilégier les produits locaux enfin à
salazie n'ya donc puisqu'on a des
cultivateurs avait par contre des cultes
ont énormément les produits au niveau du
menu très très bien très varié beaucoup
de choix personnel très accueillants et
après une sur anthony grenier
les accueillants et très conviviale la
grille se compose de quatre amis à 30
ans on va évaluer justement le menu
d'aujourd'hui sur son impression
d'ensemble de dire à ce que le simple et
xml et séduisant pour donner envie en
tout cas posé de manger ensuite on va
noter la qualité de service merkel a dit
lacan il est juste formidable
aujourd'hui
et enfin on va donner
le côté le plus perso de ce concours là
en tout cas l'évaluation c'est le bout
pour le département l'objectif de cette
opération est aussi de donner aux
collégiens des repères nutritionnels de
promouvoir les produits locaux mais
surtout de réduire le gaspillage
alimentaire
[Musique]